dans votre livre relié à vous vous
évoquez vos relations tumultueuses avec
vos quatre maris c'est toujours très
très mal terminée il soit dans la
démence selon l'hystérie alors quatre sk
sont vivants tous les quatre lui ils
vivent ensemble dans une satellite
alors on va voir ce à quoi vous seriez
prête par amour on va faire une
interview au paraguay est-ce que par
amour
est-ce que par amour vous accepteriez de
vous couper les cheveux
non non est-ce que par amour pourriez
vous mettre au repassage dit ça j'aime
j'aime ça même maintenant dans un bruit
d'accord est-ce que par amour
vous pourriez arrêter votre carrière non
parce que par amour
vous pourriez vivre sans sous vêtements
non pauvres
à oui c'est vrai je fais l'amour dans
une chose camille soldes je ne sais pas
alors de plonger
ah bon est-ce que par amour pour y est
relancé au sexe non
est-ce que par amour pour les remplacer
le sexe par la nourriture
non est-ce que par amour pourriez faire
l'impasse sur les préliminaires world is
a mean non
non non il est prête à fait rien du tout
pas à m'en voulait du mal
4 mariages et d'avoir du mal à trouver
un cinquième baril maintenant il sait
tous il ya 1 5e ils voient savoir est-ce
que par amour vous pourriez accepté de
jouer dans un film pornographique non
par amour
non si vous l'aimez non mais vous
l'aimez vraiment mais vraiment nous ça
nous ferait plaisir
alors d'accord
est-ce que par amour vous accepteriez
des gifles quoi servent ils non non
est-ce que par amour vous pourriez vivre
à seattle 6 watts initiateurs c'est une
ville z il dit tout à l'heure vers
l'enfer est-ce que par amour vous
pourriez changer de religion
ah non changez de secte est-ce que par
amour
vous accepteriez une autre fille dans
votre lit ces watts quelqu'un qui
voudrait le gardon d'al anbar non non
non non non mais vous n'êtes rien
tournez vous excepté rien de toi et tu
sois yolande bogui non est-ce que par
amour vous pourriez accepter un autre
garçon dans votre lit jack s attaquer
les animaux est-ce que par amour vous
pourriez dire des choses un peu sale en
faisant l'amour
mehdi le oui alors quoi est-ce que par
amour pour y avait lancé à tous vos amis
non si c'est le vrai le boulet amour
c'est le sait le moi si je cherche
quelque chose c'est le même
alors on renonce rien parce qu'on est
vraiment amoureux est-ce que paramo
pourriez changer de sexe ja
ouais